Stephanie Fayette: Thank you.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, and then… as we kind of jump into these exercises, I think
Jeff D'Andria: Quickly, because this human element, and whatever my term is, like, an emblem or whatever, to add.
Jeff D'Andria: I'd love, before everyone breaks out and starts tackling this themselves,
Jeff D'Andria: I'm just curious how this is, like, is this… is this making any sense? I know it's, like, an interesting, weird concept, new?
Jeff D'Andria: But if… Let me see if there's anything I want to say before you start tackling these, like…
Jeff D'Andria: I throw that word love in there, you know? Like, what do you love to do? Like…
Jeff D'Andria: outside of school stuff, and, like, on your own time. Like, no one's paying you, I just want to do that, you know? And I think…
Jeff D'Andria: Well, oftentimes, it'll be unrelated, say, again, for the software engineers in the room, just to be, for lack of a better major.
Jeff D'Andria: It may not be computer science related.
Jeff D'Andria: But I think it's just that tiebreaker of an element that shows
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, you might want… like, for me, like, one time I had a student that was a poker player.
Jeff D'Andria: professional poker player, or I had a student that
Jeff D'Andria: was… lived in Texas, and they were… worked at the Dallas Cowboys Stadium, and helped on a… was part of a crew. They turn over the stadium from football to, the next sport, and they were on the crew that would do that. Which is, like, super interesting, right? Not relevant, but, like, I think these are the kind of things that just kind of strike the human
Jeff D'Andria: Like, the human element.
Jeff D'Andria: So…
Jeff D'Andria: that's what this one is. Not a requirement, not something you have to put on. Last thing I'll say about it, one of my old colleagues, he put it like, if you're gonna put interest, kind of synonymous with hobbies or something, on your resume.
Jeff D'Andria: Make it, like, an extreme interest, not just an interest.
Jeff D'Andria: Like, are you into water sports? Or…
Jeff D'Andria: have you been on a water… like, an outrigger canoe team for 6-plus years, done, you know, 25-plus, 30-mile races? Like, that's, like, more detailed. Well, this person's passionate, like, they… they can go end-to-end on something. I don't… I'm not a water sports person, but this is, like… this is interesting, you know?
Jeff D'Andria: So… That's the thought here.
Jeff D'Andria: So yeah, I think…
Jeff D'Andria: Any questions before we… we're gonna break out and kind of tackle this one first? Depending on time, hopefully we can do both.
Jeff D'Andria: Before I read the directions. Any questions on this stuff before we hop in? And just want to encourage y'all to go
Jeff D'Andria: You know, try and leave this session having done this, so you can really literally copy and paste this onto your resume if you want to try it.
Keidra Floyd: I have a question.
Jeff D'Andria: Yep.
Keidra Floyd: Can you give an example of what, like, the closer line item would be? Like, what could we put for that?
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, actually…
Jeff D'Andria: I'm literally looking at, I'm just gonna share.
Jeff D'Andria: So this is a conversation I had…
Jeff D'Andria: Here we go, sorry, share screen.
Jeff D'Andria: So…
Jeff D'Andria: again, had some conversations. Please, this is, like, internal CTI, so don't, like, share this out or whatever, but, like, this was Mark. He was,
Jeff D'Andria: the C… God, what was his title? He was, like, the head of tech at a company called Woop, which some of you may have heard of, like, the wearable. And so we literally asked him, like, what are the three things that are most important to you in a strong hire? And then we put a line down the middle, and I said, how can they demonstrate that?
Jeff D'Andria: So, for him, a closer follows through on a task until… and this is… this is, like, an example
Jeff D'Andria: Of what he was looking for.
Jeff D'Andria: from the moment an issue started to the moment it was merged into the codebase,
Jeff D'Andria: So I'd say, like, for you, Kidra, like, if…
Jeff D'Andria: Combing through times you've worked on projects, when have you… Done something like that?
Jeff D'Andria: Does that make sense?
Keidra Floyd: Okay, yeah, that helps, thank you.
Jeff D'Andria: Cool.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, so, and that's what I'm pulling on, like.
Jeff D'Andria: after having, like, 30 of these conversations with hiring managers, we were definitely noticing, like, an archetype. They were, like, looking for kind of similar stuff, like, they're…
Jeff D'Andria: And maybe the job description doesn't call out for it, but that's why I'm like, dude, let's use that language, like, closer, that you're coachable. Like, do you have examples of when you've been coachable? Why not just throw that on? They're not asking for it in the job description, but…
Jeff D'Andria: It's what they're looking for.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, so let's, I'm gonna read the directions, and then we'll just start crafting our own.
Jeff D'Andria: I'm gonna share one more time… It goes there.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, so let's… let's, let's definitely start with, making highlights, right?
Jeff D'Andria: So… Pull up a job description of a target role that you've got in mind, or already targeting.
Jeff D'Andria: And then…
Jeff D'Andria: Scan a job description for the top 3 wants that the hiring manager is seeking in a strong candidate.
Jeff D'Andria: and add those 3 wants to this document. So, I'm gonna share a link in the chat right now, so everyone…
Jeff D'Andria: Has this… .
Sathya Narayanan: You probably need to change the sharing setting, because it looks like it's locked.
Sathya Narayanan: Okay. You share on the share on the top right?
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, let's see…
Jeff D'Andria: Sorry, anyone with the link? And then just go ahead and make a copy.
Jeff D'Andria: Hmm.
Jeff D'Andria: Sorry, I'll give you the wrong one. Ignore that one, and it's actually this one.
Sathya Narayanan: It's already shared, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: So, sorry, the one I sent was, a little bit of an outdated version, so this is…
Jeff D'Andria: This morning.
Jeff D'Andria: Like, untended?
Jeff D'Andria: Okay? So…
Jeff D'Andria: Identify the top 3 wants, take 5 minutes to yourself to do that, we'll get you into a breakout room. And then after 5 minutes, share your screen.
Jeff D'Andria: I… Displaying the job description, and sh… with your partner, share why you chose these three wants.
Jeff D'Andria: And just kind of bounce off your partner, just to kind of…
Jeff D'Andria: hear their opinion, their suggestions, just to go through that process a little bit together. Take 5 minutes, split that 5 minutes, so, like, two and a half minutes each.
Jeff D'Andria: And then, take 10 minutes and write up Kind of down here.
Jeff D'Andria: What is your specific example, your relevant example for that? Thing number one. So I have an example, like, maybe they're looking for a machine learning experience. Maybe they're looking for…
Jeff D'Andria: Looks like collaboration teamwork's important. Okay, when have I done that?
Jeff D'Andria: Maybe they want a closer, you know?
Jeff D'Andria: And then, this is, like, bonus, feel free to…
Jeff D'Andria: Tackle this as you feel fit… see fit, but really curious in that kind of a sentence that aligns you and the company, the problem they're working on, and what would that sentence be for you?
Jeff D'Andria: Okay?
Jeff D'Andria: Last thing I'll say here.
Jeff D'Andria: the more specific, this is from the conversation with Ashby today.
Jeff D'Andria: they really want you to be specific, like, the more technical detail, like, what was the biggest problem you worked on in this example, what was your process, you know? They want, really, you to be specific, not too… not just generic and kind of like, I got this done in, like, 5 words. They want detail.
Jeff D'Andria: And honestly, that detail is what, as the AI is combing through the resumes to whittle down from hundreds to, like, here's the 50 you might want to look at, recruiter, they need those details. They need those keywords, you know?
Jeff D'Andria: To, to make you findable.
Jeff D'Andria: Alright, so Nancy,
Jeff D'Andria: Why don't we all come back here in 20 minutes? Looks like we're gonna have time to just do one of these.
Jeff D'Andria: And then we can kind of chat about how that went. But can you break them off into groups of, two?
Jeff D'Andria: Partners?
Nancy Rios: Yeah, let me see.
Nancy Rios: Hmm.
Jeff D'Andria: Any last questions before we do that?
Monalisa Nchinda: Yeah, I have a question. How important is it that our resume is only one page? Because I've often heard that, anything over one page, they don't look at it.
Jeff D'Andria: No rule on it, but it's definitely the most competitive stance, I'd say. For coming right out of school, like y'all are, one page is, like, the most competitive stance.
Jeff D'Andria: And that was actually something the Ashby person cost the thousands of companies. That's something he actually pointed out today.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah, Kevin mentioned it, and I think the way he mentioned it was, it shows your ability to kind of be precise and prioritize, or something like that. I forgot, I can look at the slides, so they almost look at it as if you're writing too much.
Sathya Narayanan: you don't have, like, kind of a focus kind of, kind of a thing, so I would say it's a, it's a pretty strong yes on the one… one page. And, yeah.